hey I was going for us my name is anyone
still watching I sure as hell wouldn't
welcome to life is strange today we're
gonna play through episode 3 this has
been an amazing game so far I really
really loved it
I'm very excited to check out what's
gonna happen it's called chaos theory
which fits for the whole going back in
time and [ __ ]
I think they talked about in the first
episode in this crazy episode that life
is strange film little pieces of time
[Music]
freak it totally makes sense you hella
saved my life I think it's awesome you
set a tongue record on video and we're
going to be sorry someday and this is
how are you doing Matt hi Joyce I am so
sorry about William I have great
memories of him that was his gift to us
wonderful memories let's talk about your
superpower hey Stella and Louise you're
my business now Rachel's bracelet why
the [ __ ] are you wearing her bracelet
you want me to cut you [ __ ] please step
back
you're kidding put that down
nobody cares about me
nobody way she I don't really jump what
are you doing here Mac now I know today
was difficult for everybody miss coffee
why exactly were you on the route with
Kate Marsh please tell us everything
what the hell is this max there was no
Eclipse scheduled today I believe you
Warren I believe anything this week yes
I'm scared of talking cuz every time I
know like someone else could be I don't
want to interrupt the game you know I'm
saying
but I was gonna say that I showed one
was so [ __ ] good and then when
episode two came it was I had a bit
higher expectations for it but I have I
am I'm still hope for episode 3 I know
you can do it
[Music]
just for relaxing atmospheric pieces
like this that I really love it it's in
the small details prose that's how you
make a good game
[Music]
wait suspend away I have a guinea pig
Jesus Christ how did I not know this
s with us and waking up abruptly Jesus
Christ
[Music]
have somebody show me meet me in front
of the campus get data a s in gear now
it would be all over this so I better
get moving
oh it's a bunny I still can't stop
thinking about Kate second awakened a
bad dream nobody messes with me [ __ ] I
feel like if I really wanted to get back
on someone I'd just ruin their thing the
whole thing I wouldn't just do it down
there this would be a cool picture
though we're in it I'm trying to look at
it game what are you trying to make me
do okay that's interesting let's look in
the mirror well we may get it get that
ass in gear the oh why can't I not seem
to click on anything what is this there
we go
they changed their controls midway
through they were fine okay this is Gary
dark let there be light maybe I should
play with my controllers dad that
doesn't work okay
this is library anything can happen Wow
giddap I hear quality less player on
YouTube I wouldn't really call myself
and see if this works
yes so much better wood controller
that's creepy
hi yeah how you doing what's up Dana hey
Dana how are you doing I just can't stop
thinking about Kate and if this is my
fault - I think we're all responsible I
think we're all responsible for what
happened
not you max you were close to her you
are nice to Kate that's all she needed
from everybody else here tell that's a
Victoria and the vortex Club Dana
there's more to this than just Victoria
in the vortex Club being mean so what
exactly are you saying max you think
this has something to do with Nathan
being expelled it's complicated
I don't want to drag you into this okay
not yet anyway
I'm getting scared now but people here
are still sneaking out tonight
what like who Victoria bounced out of
here earlier and now you Sherlock not me
I need a break from today get some sleep
- Dana I'll see you later
what's looking at her laptop Wow Trevor
is a sweetie right in front of her good
for Dana if Dana talks to Juliette about
this she's gonna wish she didn't I feel
like I'm spying on them
I should not be reading these she's
right there man come on man
whoa creepy light this is a horror game
Jesus ring Victoria isn't here maybe
I'll just wait and bide my time going
through your [ __ ]
no and we're not gonna do that she may
be an [ __ ] but I ain't no ass how old
girl so Chloe is waiting for me in front
of the main hall thank you for reminding
us I actually forgot main hall that's
out here isn't it this is nice
Akshay no keys are all broken wells are
you serious oh I'm toast if he sees me
okay we better hide ho buddy can expel
me not yet anyway
oh [ __ ] he's right [ __ ] there
hmm how do we do this
feeling sorry for yourself when Kay
barks it's family is in mourning
they'll probably sue the Academy right
out of Oregon the most magical insects
burn bright broken light a totem what's
the goddamn to it and adding to being
neither the two Banga does look pretty
scary at night please don't destroy me
it's our diary
oh my god I want to hurt him marry him
eautiful
okay we got a text message didn't we I
guess we should reply before we go out
isn't isn't that what do you do
wait we have an unread from Victoria
hey [ __ ] feminazis will be exterminated
watch out keep your how are we
effeminate see what the hell man
are you popping them out okay we need
this figure out how to get past this guy
and I don't know why okay let's try and
fail one time see we can rewind time
anyway so don't mind me oh [ __ ] you have
to be stealthier than that you're not
supposed to be outside your dormitory at
this hour know that I'm sorry principal
I'm sure you're not supposed to be drunk
I'm still upset about Kate I need some
air and space to walk I'm sorry you had
to go through that today
you tried to help but god damn it
Blackwell is my responsibility and I I
let her and Kate down so they actually
just go on back inside get some rest
it's been a shitty day good night max
you can't tell me what to do how do I
get past him to meet Chloe um let's see
if there's a way around it you can't
tell me what to do
oh babe a place you got wet I need food
let's follow these fireflies that's
gotta be it
can't really see where I'm going I know
nobody's knowing I checked out the flood
supply whichever way the wind is blowing
man that was a sick freestyle yo how do
I come on main now am I am I this stupid
maybe we can break the other lamps
because one of them is broken right
let's look at the broken lamp and see
what happened all right that's a broken
lamp let's look at it maybe Samuel
should fix that lamp let's check here in
the electricity cabinet maybe that's it
yeah there is something here bingo it's
unlocked Jesus Christ
I hope Sammy wasn't around this is scary
as [ __ ] oh my god they should have a
horror episode would that be so cool
nothing I forgot I'm legit terrified
Lulu Samuel was so into runway fashion
of course runway fashion I love that
[ __ ] - don't tell my CLO it's my seat
it's our secret
I know Samuel doesn't wear silky scarves
so who does hey don't judge a man for
wanting to wear some silky scarfs
gendered label a ler whatever okay there
has to be a switch here there has to be
a reason I can go in here nothing but
tools
what's wrong with tools nothing here
okay
[Music]
it's the clue to the puzzle was to go
back so much that's before he locks
himself out that way we'll catch him
while he's still [ __ ] about with his
little a door thing and we can just
sneak right on back it's just a pretty
[ __ ] weird name set of keys on me I
don't know man gotcha why would they
leave that place openings
it really seemed like that was the case
am i that's stupid breath all right
happy hour hopefully I won't get stuck
again right away god damn it and it took
so long to rewinds I just assumed that
that wasn't what I was supposed to do
Jesus Christ woman what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you boo yeah like I was scary
Punk ghost yeah [ __ ]
yeah right okay I watched my friend jump
off a roof today I don't think you need
to prank me tonight you always trip out
on me for not being there for you but is
this how you're there for me wow she got
real there I'm sorry max I wasn't even
thinking I suck
I'm not trying to be a [ __ ] but I'll
never get the image out of my head of
Kate jumping off that roof all because
my power didn't work
attending [ __ ] I know seeing Kate Paul
was horrible I don't even know how to
deal with that so I just act like an
idiot but it's your badass power that's
gonna bring all this to a close we just
need to connect the players and find out
who really killed Kate we have to stop
this from happening to anybody else
oh yeah and somehow stop that tornado
from wiping out Arcadia Bay right
didn't you say that it was all about
chaos theory I don't see any control
over this chaos oh right
except for your ability to oh yeah
manipulate time and space no biggie
Chloe I just feel weird about some of my
decisions especially after I just got
Nathan expelled
dude do not even torture yourself like
that let's focus on looking for clues
okay I don't know what she would know by
Kate let's act about Rachel we need to
find out more about who Rachel was
involved with around here she was able
to blend in with everybody you know with
people I hate it and even though I don't
know her it feels like Rachel is guiding
us to the truth [ __ ] the truth I just
want to find my friend right now it
scares me to think where she could be do
you think she's dead I'm sorry I hate
even saying that Chloe not as much as I
hate thinking it max we have to find
Rachel soon we have to I promise you we
will like you said it's time to start
the search for clues now tell me what's
your secret
drum roll please I present the spare
keys to Blackwell thank you step prick
you are such a boss Chloe
such a boss I just don't want you to get
into any more trouble look at all the
trouble dropping in Arcadia Bay at this
point who gives a [ __ ] anymore okay win
it max did she just read out insert
groan here if she read out one of the
captions mechanically the rest of the
class will follow your lead I'm sorry I
was distracted us you know it's not been
a good day for Blackwell I know this has
been an awful day and you can talk to me
anytime mr. Jefferson Thank You Victoria
I imagine
you're pretty upset over Kate as well
I'm like still in shock I've never seen
anybody die I really cared about Katie
Katie she's such a [ __ ] I had no idea
you two were that close
did she well how does this affect the
everyday heroes contest it doesn't the
contest is still ago and I still have to
pick the winner to best represent
Blackwell I've got all the photos except
one from Max I'll give you a one-word
sneak preview of Max's photo selfie
listen you've seen my entry you know
what's better than that
wouldn't it be so cool to hang out
together in San Francisco mark stick to
mr. Jefferson Victoria please and I
haven't picked the winner yet you
already love my work so it's not like
you're playing favorites just imagine if
you picked my photo though we would have
to spend a lot of time together that
could be fun don't you think
I'm going to think that you didn't say
any of that you might as well choose me
otherwise I might have to tell people
you offered to choose my photo for
favors as a favor to your future I'll
also ignore that undisguised threat this
conversation is officially over miss
chase I suggest you go back to your dorm
now wait are you [ __ ] kidding me oh
we should we should shank her this is
two versus one she'll grab her by your
head I'll stick a [ __ ] night in her
throat so did I say that out loud I I
meant of course we'll shave our heads
let's go find out that's what we need to
do you know if you take a carrot and you
peel it you peel it enough that it sits
it's a pole you can kill someone with a
carrot Chloe the keymaster I know this
because of
references in the past dark ages dude I
don't know about this don't want to get
it what dudes are in so much trouble not
to mention the week we ran into my room
joking I'm serious we're not kids
anymore we're breaking and entering if I
have a key how can it be breaking I get
charges for just entering I'm serious we
could go to jail
not if I'm related to the head of
Blackwell's security steps it will do
not want me in the hands the local
police so we better find out what's in
the principal's office first you can
rewind if we get caught right you have
mad powers yeah exactly how that's a
Kate come on one more door and our work
here is done I like this this is cool
this is cool I could get expelled but I
got superpowers so we don't matter good
it don't matter what
it don't matter girl no matter what the
otters oh they're my favorite swimming
team of all time
no be shot was not her a trendy hot I
feel bad for the twee hipster who lost
his beret bet he's cute I feel bad for
the twee hipster who lost his beret bet
he's cute I feel bad for the tweet
hipster who lost his beret bet he's cute
I have nothing nothing to say to that
only a total phony would wear a crappy
hat like that the [ __ ] is up with our
and their judgement of hats hockey damn
man that's it really that's all I had to
do the [ __ ] the security officers should
have the key to the principal's office
he's hiding [ __ ] like everybody here
mm-hmm well now we definitely have to
get this door open
believe it or not I know a little about
lock picking thanks to Frank I might as
well test out my a thief skill go for it
we're already in this deep well you
could look for the key just in case why
yes I could all right I ran I ran the
key of COS of cos prayers of course the
K is the K and L exact it's in the wee
hipster or the key rack here are the
keys
none for the principal's office well
that was fast
I bet it is why would it be if I was a
key to the principal's office I would
not put it in any of the drawers maybe
someone borrowed it recently nothing
here
I don't want to go that way oh my god
you scare the [ __ ] out of me every time
calm down woman I'm just trying to play
video games video games trying to play
video games well I guess I'll be
checking all the [ __ ] drawers in
nothing here okay these are all file
cabinets
not gonna waste my time with those well
what about these desolation no key for
thee we have to find another way in
guess I didn't spend enough time with
Frank but I'll use my DIY lock pick
tools while you come up with a better
plan we could just kick down the door
get the information and then rewind
hey Warren you busy just bubble her
you'll be okay listen I need your
physics expertise stat what's without
naming names if somebody had access to
the art and science labs and wanted to
construct a device that would say open a
locked door would you maybe kind of know
how huh no I'm just asking for fun
thanks science guy
no no stay we need you as backup
just in the text instructions now of
course I'm still all indigo ape with you
at the drive-in thanks for the help
Olathe ass goddamn door try not to wake
up everybody at blackwell sorry max I
got nothing what about your plan all
right we need sugar soda gonna take duct
tape can you stay here and not get
caught I might get on the other side of
that door before you Lupin the race is
on see you soon oh it's a race isn't it
how about that here's how you do it oh
my god that is the most awesome picture
I've seen in my left
[Music]
good thing we're we text it so now
where's evidence classic nerd where do
you go okay sugar soda can duct tape so
let's see if I can find those items I do
yeah
trash all right we'll [ __ ] you - then
where was the chemistry lab again it's
here isn't it bathroom
just emptied nothing here
release the Kraken oh my god stop you're
gonna be the death of me
it's all mine anyway a bad Evan Matt
available items to go sugar this is the
canvas your mats and a itis I gotta
literally all the drawers are open I
hate that formal and smell I love it oh
boy I would have again only a b-minus
Warren has shattered my face uh haha of
course
I'm barely passing science that's harsh
that's sugar what the [ __ ] sugar what
are you doing there baby
Oh sugar that was easy enough you're
halfway home max yeah I'm still here
talk to you later Nate I hate it
everybody's asleep I hate to wake them
up but I want a picture
[Music]
good evening fish fish
thanks fish nice work thanks fish you
should probably turn it off then please
resume your slumbers
[Music]
I chemistry stuff of cause you're an
artist dammit not a scientist but this
is so not sodium chlorate so not huh
boom Krause at least switch to e6 gotta
teach kids not to smoke don't smoke kids
at least switch to e-cigs if you have to
smoke at least switch to e6 sprout all
right here we go
No this mixture does not work Duff not
get damaged your session just calm down
all right I can't keep up with this
alright it must be here then no are you
kidding me where the hell else would we
find it honestly
Vulcan now mate alright let's check the
text messages again Bruce we got this in
the bag
I can feel any money every time I'm
sister I burp so you know it's true oh
we still don't have duct tape that could
be in the generator enforcement
mmm-hmm see this is legit scary I don't
know what it is with schools and [ __ ]
darkness what is this art class I think
there might be duck tipping there oh
maybe they use sodium this is like the
scene in a horror film this is what I
said literally five seconds ago Jesus
Christ that's even scarier oh let's look
at the context why is he here eight even
when you were sad you tried to see the
good in the world [ __ ] Victoria that is
pretty [ __ ] sweet how can I hate
somebody that shoots like that yeah
that's that's a pretty nice paint
picture heals a better illustrator than
photographer said max the art critic yep
you haven't even put yours in there I
feel gross even looking at Nathan's work
but he does have some style the [ __ ]
does that mean
you're such a judge full of prick
cigarette what's up with this Victoria's
cigarettes I'm sure mr. Jefferson is
impressed max if you can't find sodium
chlorite in the science lab give it up
yes our ingredient left at least switch
to e6 okay there must be here
okay we could not find it in this
science lab is that what she meant I
[Music]
mean yeah why would we find it anywhere
else he did give us a clue didn't he
What did he say again sorry I forgot I
like although her dad is just a hipster
[ __ ] wall my dad so much okay let's
see here
okay so it's a powder I mean really
honestly where the Halliwell's would we
look right am i right
let's ask her if she knows hey you know
where I can find some powder I bet you
do
hey oh no all right I'm so sorry
squirrels like nuts does that mean
Samuel is nah
Samuel is gay
[Music]
is that it
I probably should find those items now
yeah you know what you know what I'm
doing right now you know I'm doing you
know what I'm trying to do here
take a guess just just one guess what
I'm trying to do here
just one little what about the restroom
may be it seemed like a cleaning
equipment that'd be cool no max if you
can't find sodium chlorite in the
science lab give it up
is that a hint to something I don't
understand I don't trust this game
anymore
this game has broken my trust too many
times friends
I did I do think she has a point though
like it should really be in there
Jeanette
this is a science lab and it's
let's give this one more try
what about here
come on sodium chloride ding I never
said they were great troll
it was god damn trolls man there's just
no controlling them
so sodium chlorate is a weak killer
you'd think Warren would have told me
that factoid yeah actually I did think
he would tell me some more clue then I
just say that so using weed killer okay
we look that [ __ ] up by our cell phone
how about that how about this
alright so weed killer that can be using
gardening and [ __ ] max if you can't find
sodium chlorite in the science lab give
it up
[Music]
was there any I'm looking for like a
tray from the cleaning lady you know
there weed killer it should be outside
I'm well confused mate a weed killer
you'd think Warren would have told me
that factoid why am I even doing this
canvasses [ __ ]
Berenice oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god
are you are you are you it's gonna drop
on my face and my father's gonna mill
Sonic's don't waste your rewind power
use the damn chair I don't know we did
it put the chair back girl [ __ ] my chair
put the chair back there just a prayer
but you put all right let's go to the
chemistry let's get let's go to the
chemistry lab girls let's go to the
chemistry our let's go to the cabbage
real a girl up Oh what am i doing so I'm
just gonna go back I'm not gonna make
the actual thing here well that seems
kind of irresponsible but all right then
splash some water on your face splashing
water on your face Oh special water on
your face girl I can't stop
alright where was she Yeah right I don't
I still don't know where the [ __ ] I'm
going there it is I sure hope this works
she's like yeah I got it I did it all by
myself maybe you should give up take it
easy on the door Chloe let's try this
yeah let's try it let's try my bump
literally yes time to blow [ __ ] up yeah
if you light the candle if we're on em
it's so cold ocean Jesus Christ get
ready to haul ass
that was so [ __ ] cool that was pretty
[ __ ] cool oh we are toast
here comes the whole Arcadia Bay Fire
and Police Department ah so what should
we do well we need to get it aside
[Music]
nothing
if I keep sharing me what happened
think max rewind in mind something
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
that's cool welcome to my domain oh you
are the magic I have no clue how the
hell you got in there but you did it
sister sister company Nike now
let's find what we want and beat it my
powers only go so far
man I can see why the principal locks
this room up
fancy faux art crap you must want
everybody to know he has money but no
taste yeah like you have taste how can
you trust somebody who has a [ __ ]
bronze bird in his office a bronze bird
lover yes if only the principal had a
Monet or Picasso you'd still be a black
whoa
oh I'm gonna pill for the papers on this
ugly ass desk you're gonna what
okay sure it's ugly but damn is it a
cozy chair this is your chance to truly
get all deductive and [ __ ] Sherlock
find us some clues about Rachel Kate
Nathan anybody I'm on the case how do
you how do you know it's not your chance
god dammit girl that's nice this is
pretty much sums up Kate shy and sweet
and in the wrong place okay only two
more
you're incredible our files to go what
did I say it in here look at this pile
look at this pile look at this pile I'm
looking look at this part okay I got it
look at this Jesus Jesus Christ
tumbleweeds god I love tumble penis we
heard this [ __ ] has a spotless record
he stands as a proud representation of
blackwell Wow I want like I'm not gonna
read my own personal file oh my god max
as you prefer to be called this cuz it
quiet and attentive is it with much
potential for geography the schools
really do this update despite some
recent comforting black surgeon max try
to unsuccessfully stop tell a student
what file is going to be so spotless a
projectile vomit Wow I have to make sure
Warren doesn't have a criminal
background like any [ __ ] teacher know
their students that well [ __ ] please
they don't give a [ __ ] let's nab this
last file Sherlock always wanted Rachel
doesn't seem so troubled based on all
this but there's not much here about the
police investigation hmm man I don't
blame the principal for expelling Chloe
bad Chloe Wow Wow I think we found
everything in here I should go join
Chloe now so Chloe you playing candy
crush over there
yes you better come check out these
files nathan accuses rachael of bringing
drugs on campus and my step troll went
along because he thinks the rachel was a
bad influence on me [ __ ] if David is
teaming up with Nathan Prescott that's a
bad sign I know a bad sign when I sell
out the third ooh he's so money and you
know the Prescotts dropped major bank to
Barry Nathan's real file look it reads
like a rap sheet bad grades teacher
complaints secret probation but I was
expelled
at least Nathan was finally suspended
check out that note open it it's just
some crazy drawing it's not a drawing
look Rachel into darkroom Rachel in read
me over and over that's it that's [ __ ]
up what does this even mean Nathan is
truly psychotic I know he has something
to do with Rachel missing whoa listen to
this David M always asks what's going on
in my head David M always helps me
follow those he follows it's pretty
cryptic no it sounds like they formed
some sort of weird team the superheroes
Jesus David was stalking Kate hassling
me and now we know he was all over
Rachel too oh we are so going into his
garage files plus I'm getting a little
paranoid in here we got our info let's
bail but maybe we shouldn't leave
without a gift no you are not taking the
cozy chair master your powers include
mind-reading or did you just rewind
because I tried to steal the chair ha ha
ha ha I'm confused it's the powers of
friendship I know how are you wrong I
know why you saw a girl I got a baby
Cheri we pressed our luck oh no what
have we here chocolate holy [ __ ] jackpot
James Wow sir that's a lot for the
handicapped fund dude there's $5,000
here I could pay Frank back tonight
this will chill him out after our knife
showdown yesterday are you gonna make a
big issue out of this or just rewind and
take the greenbacks for yourself I hope
you do that instead of lecturing me
let's be honest here Frank knows things
about Rachel and he might talk if he's
been paid right you are super max oh and
with the leftover dough I'll take you on
a road trip to Portland for the day
we'll stock up on tats
beer weed doughnuts and books from
Powell's and strip clubs kidding but you
never know by chair so much for taking
that money yeah yeah ain't nobody know
when nobody's going that impish look
scares me yeah care for a midnight swim
the Blackwell pool is our swimming you
want to take that risk now yeah in a
cray week we deserve a little mindless
fun in the water we're done for the
night anyway we're rich and nobody
busted us so splish Splash you're right
we hella deserve it splish Splash did
you actually just say hella I think I'm
a good bad influence on you it's
believed its place
[Music]
I'm well excited for this [ __ ]
can't believe we're doing this we're so
cray we're in the Otters lair big
[ __ ] deal
I want that heated water we still have
to play it cool okay I still go to
school here you can own this hellhole
once you figure out your rewind power
Chloe is so psyched for girls night out
so I better follow her evil plan all
right let's play splice each other if
you know I'm not gonna look at this [ __ ]
why would I look at an ad inside a video
game come on man come on now come on now
let's not be weird about this so how do
I do this it's dr. boys or girls girls
girls of course girls ooh la la
let me check to see if the pools heated
what is going on here breasts all right
well I guess we're going in
creepy as always otters eat beavers make
a good point
a bus ticket was she going to run away
like Rachel amber that's a nice clue
isn't it
interesting those look like the most
cozy comfy towels Intel history want
[Music]
some of the monologues in this game I
just love it so much does that other
sock go I don't know probably that Dewey
hipster that you were [ __ ] on Brooks
lager
my sweet people are leaving with one
truck wants to go to the drive-in with
Warren who doesn't want to go to the
driving meet Warren am i right am i
right this isn't a desperate cry for
attention or anything why would you
write your own name on a graffiti oh
here we are
max try to find the light for the pool I
want to see the Sharks otters don't like
sharks they bite
so do I hit that light what the [ __ ] was
that all about the light rescue board I
don't think anybody has ever drowned
here I hope is that a hint to the future
we can look at this this was empty
the guys must like their pink goo bell
is that what the [ __ ] are you thinking
alright let's hit that light I suppose
oh that's a shock
just when I said I need to go back in
the water Sandin pittypat you came back
to me where are you going don't worry
Shannon I got this I got I got I got
disco ahh
where's the lights why do I always miss
the small details man I'm [ __ ] trying
me if I could try it oh [ __ ] you scared
of Cheramie [ __ ] walls man
oh god don't tell me untrap [ __ ] sake
the hell man
I love the sound of the water makes me
feel all good inside and all right why
is that light is it here
what is it light Oh God
ah here here it is there has to be a
control panel for the lights around here
there it is there no alarm at this
school
alright let's look at some teenager
singh bikini yes
that's what I'm talking about this is
pretty awesome time to do or dive max so
gorgeous this game seriously are you
gonna go in or what like oh yeah baby
feels like a hot tub with my cash - I'm
queen of the world bow tell me you're
not gonna stand there watching me like a
zombie don't you dare come stop me hippy
okay you asked for it okay now I ship
them so much
cowabunga why look an otter in my water
dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun
you are so obvious and I still get
freaked out by that movie so stop I
can't even watch any of those shark
shows this is the cutest goddamn thing
I've seen in my life
[Music]
I'll just rewind in harpooneers otters
revenge cheater yeah you wouldn't know
about that
[Music]
I wish Rachel was here she would totally
love being in here at night
wish you guys had met each other we will
with all his stuff going on I'm starting
to think everything is related and I
want to find out why for Kate's sake she
didn't deserve to die your power is
changing everything max especially you I
can already tell you're not some chicken
[ __ ] anymore thanks girlfriend you know
what I need you're becoming like this
force of nature more like luck of nature
come on my power failed trying to rescue
Caine
maybe I'm just stumbling back and forth
in time for what reason you didn't
stumble when you saved me max
not that time but that's because you
were there to kick-start my power so
it's time to start moving forward in
time and we're obviously connected since
without me you would have never
discovered your power right
[Music]
absolutely you make me feel like I know
what I'm doing
then do you make me feel like I have a
reason for still being in Arcadia Bay I
hope so
stop being so goddamn humble you're like
the smartest most talented person I've
ever known
more than Rachel amber dude I'm not her
groupie okay and I'm sure you have
Blackwell Bros all over you like Warren
you're the bro killer tats and - you did
not just say that
plus I am NOT down with these Arcadia
Bay hillbillies I don't blame you anyway
we have bigger fish to fry
right no worries once you get over
yourself you're gonna make the world bow
as long as you're there with me don't
look so sad I'm never leaving you but
it's the sweetest thing all right Bruce
I'm sorry but I'm gonna have to end that
episode there if you want to watch the
rest of this episode click here or in
linked in the description it will take
you there and I'll see I'll see you bros
in the next one as always stay awesome
breasts